let's go to Ryan from New Hampshire Ryan
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
hey can you hear me David yes I can
awesome
um so I just had a quick question kind
of a theory almost
um
so with RFK Jr uh more appealing to like
anti-vaccine voters and um
like moderates or sorry moderates who
are less happy with Democrats yeah
um
do you see him to be like
kind of trying to do what Trump did
where he appeals to like more Fringe
right-wing views and also more moderate
people
I don't know that that's necessarily
what Trump tried to do I think I mean
listen let me tell you what I do think
about the Bobby Kennedy like what is his
constituency who who is it that would
consider voting for him and I do think
you're on to something which is it's
slivers of both sides which isn't a good
or bad thing you could say hey let me
give you a hypothetical imagine you had
a candidate that was able to unite
the part of the left that is more
Progressive
on economic issues ETC and the part of
the right that is more into like a Chris
Christie or John McCain who realizes
that Maga is wrong I would go that's
great that's a great Alliance of left
and right I think the issue with Bobby
Kennedy is that he's putting together a
constituency that's not exactly the best
of right and left it's arguably close to
the worst it's the people on the left
who refuse to even consider that Joe
Biden has done some good things and
potentially are anti-vaccine or
conspiracy theorists on covet or
whatever the case may be as well as some
of the right-wing people who are
essentially Maga people but they just
don't know that Trump's the right
vehicle for their views so he is in a
sense uniting some people from left and
right but it's not people that I'm super
impressed with as a constituency
yep that's what was that my concern was
that the cons the voters that he would
get together I don't know how much they
would agree with voting with each other
based on their views yeah 100 100 and
listen we'll see the guy's got 12 or so
percent on average if you look at this
like that is something that is
definitely something and we'll see what
he does with it
yep it's just interesting for me to see
um how he plans on going up against uh
Joe Biden if he gets there it's just
very interesting to me that will be
interesting to see all right Ryan thank
you so much thank you very much David
all right thank you everybody who called
in we're going to take a break we will
take calls again I can never get to
everybody so please don't hate me for it
I got emails David you didn't get to me
I apologize but let's take a break and
then the program will continue